Consider this spiffy, new finite state machine.
It accepts both 1 or more letters like word--w-o-r-d--and also 1 or more digits--1, 2, 3.
In fact, there's a sense in which it accepts either [a - z]+ or [0 - 9]+.
Note its 2 accepting states. Such power!
Can we do the same thing with regular expressions?
It turns out we can with a new regular expression operator,
a nubitive syntax in regular expressions that I'm going to teach you.
This vertical bar means I match either the thing on the left or the thing on the right.
It's formally called 'disjunction' sometimes, but we can just read it as 'or'.
Match [a - z]+ or [0 - 9]+.
For example, let's say we want to find all matches of lowercase [a - z]+ or [0 - 9]+
in "Goethe 1749".
We'll get both 'oethe' and '1749'.
We don't get the capital G because we asked for lowercase letters over here.
One of Goethe's most famous works is Faust, in which an old man makes
a literal deal with the devil in an incredible surprise move. It does not go particularly well.
And in fact, the phrase Faustian bargain has entered the modern English lexicon
meaning a deal that you really don't want to make or where you're giving up too much
to get something.
While we're here, our old friend regular expression [0 - 2] is really just 0/1/2.
So I could write out [a - z] as 26 different choices, but that's not very concise.